il est 8h ce matin quand le convoi
s'engouffre par l'arrière du tribunal de
vesoul
derrière ses vitres teintées impossible
de distinguer la silhouette de johnatan
d'aval transférés sous haute sécurité
depuis la maison d'arrêt de dijon son
arrivée discrète est suivie par celle
bien plus agité de ses avocats qui n'ont
pas souhaité s'exprimer avant l'audience
alors que les interrogations sont encore
nombreuses du côté des parties civiles
la première question était de savoir
pourquoi lui qu'on aimait tant
faut dire que c'était le deuxième fils
de la famille pourquoi j'ai fait ça et
pourquoi surtout après at il adopté une
stratégie de défense aussi une grotesque
que cap chat
c'est à ces questions là qu'on attend
des réponses l'émotion est palpable
quand les proches d'alexia d'aval arrive
sur le parvis du palais de justice
ses parents sa soeur et son beau-frère
tous sont d'abord là pour alexia on sait
qu'on va être très bien défendu
qu'alexia vet c'est le procès de joe
natale et je ne veux pas que ce soit le
procès d' alex young vous appréhendez de
le voir je peux voir non non
à l'époque on dire on va se faire bon
écoute et vous dire apprendre seul
johnatan d'aval pourra lui aussi compter
sur le soutient ses proches
malgré les restrictions sanitaires sa
mère martine henry assistera finalement
au procès qui doit durer jusqu'à
vendredi